Okay, so now let's get to the, uh, reaction
from Donald Trump to this just blockbuster
scandal where Donald Trump is accused not
just of wanting to collude with Ukraine for
his benefit in the 2020 election, but of allegedly
withholding $250 million in aid unless you
cranes smears Joe Biden to help Trump in 2020.
We already looked at what Trump's TV lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani said about this.
He went on Chris Cuomo and he said, I never
had Ukraine do anything about Biden.
Then immediately said, of course I asked Ukraine
to investigate Joe Biden and when Chris Cuomo
calls him out for it, he says, I never denied
saying that.
I talked to Ukraine about Joe Biden.
That was all within like 35 seconds.
Okay.
We talked about that earlier in the show.
We now are getting two video of a visibly
red and disheveled looking Donald Trump, particularly
red and disheveled.
Here is Trump with of course a helicopter
in the background making it extremely difficult
to hear anything anybody is saying and Trump
admits that.
Yes, the topic of Joe Biden did come up during
the meeting during the phone call with the
Ukrainian president back in July.
That part is clear and then of course it's
just details.
Take a look at this.
We had a great conversation.
A conversation I had was largely congratulatory,
was largely corruption.
All of the corruption.
Second play was largely due to the fact that
we don't want our people like Vice President
Biden is done creating fittings, get corrupted
already and the you brain and your brain,
your brain's got a lot of problems.
The new president is saying that he's going
to be able to do rich, the country of corruption
that I said that would be a great thing.
We had a great conversation.
We had a conversation on many things.
In fact, I believe you framed, put out a statement
yesterday that we covered many different topics.
There was a warm and friendly conversation.
We backside back refrain from the beginning,
so there Trump says, yeah, we did talk about
Joe Biden.
We talked about how people like Joe Biden
and his son are bad and they should be kept
out of power, which is of course not a denial
of exactly what it is that is being reported.
Trump just not going far enough and admitting
the full details of that.
The report was Biden was discussed and that
part is of course true.
The next question is are the details about
not agreeing to a White House meeting with
the Ukrainian president and withholding 250
million in military aid because Ukraine has
not yet smeared Biden.
Is that part true?
But we've got part one, which is Trump admits
Biden did come up during that phone call.
Now here's another clip.
This is more yelling over the chopper.
Trump asked if Rudy Giuliani is involved here
and Trump says he would love to have Rudy
Giuliani involved and of course, once again
another point is confirmed.
We suspected that Rudy Giuliani was involved.
Rudy Giuliani more recently on Chris cuomos
program on CNN after denying that he was involved
in talking to Ukraine about Biden admits it
and here Donald Trump's saying it would be
great if Rudy Giuliani was involved.
Well, I would have no problem with Rudy's.
A very straight shooter has already wants
to see the same thing as a lot of other people.
With respect to your brain, Ukraine has had
a tremendous corruption problem.
Somehow they were involved in a lot of different
things that took place in our country and
hopefully it can be straight down and I will
say the new president, very good enough.
The new president got elected based on the
fact that he would end corruption.
That was probably his number one thing.
Then Trump just repeats.
Listened to me like a crazy person and then
concoct some cockamamie conspiracy theory
about Joe Biden while still defending the
phone call with the Ukrainian president.
Listen to me.
Listen, listen, listen to me.
I assume many people are on the line.
I know that before I make the call.
And that's where you have intelligence agencies.
Everybody listening.
That call was a great coach, is a perfect
call, a perfect all perfect is the horrible
thing that Joe Vies said and now we made a
lie.
What he said, he never spoke to his son.
I mean, give me a break.
He's already said he spoke to his side and
now he said yesterday, very firmly, you start,
of course you fuck your son.
So he made the mistake of saying he never
spoke to his son.
He spoke to his son.
But more importantly what he said about the
billions of dollars that he wouldn't give
them unless they fired the prosecutor.
I bet he bragged about how they fired the
prosecutor.
They got the money.
These are the rantings of a disheveled madman.
It's I, I'm not trying to make fun of anyone
when I say this, but Trump is not only now
sounding like the guy on the subway platform
yelling at you about the fifth coming of Zeus
or something while urinating on the third
whale.
Trump is also looking like that guy.
And here he is with more conspiracy theories
saying Biden, China, sell out something, something.
Well, not only take a look at China, they
took a tremendous amount of money out of China.
Now they ever took over his China negotiation.
He would sell us out.
Look at all the money paid in China at the
sun.
He knew nothing, but John is just stiff.
We knew nothing.
How did he strike, you know, hundreds of thousands
and millions of dollars.
I didn't get the same thing in Ukraine.
He knows nothing.
This is a very dishonest thing that Joe Biden
did that he said he never spoke to his son.
Anybody believes that one.
So
this is the new corruption.
This is the new treason.
This is the new bribery.
And we're all just sort of getting used to
it.
And just looking at Trump in this video, you
can tell that he's not well never mind, you
know, listening to the absolutely ridiculous
things that he's saying and we've gotten used
to it.
You Look Online, you look at the comments
on these videos and it's overwhelmingly things
from left and right.
Uh, yeah, this is sort of crazy, but this
is just Trump.
Uh, is it drugs?
We don't know.
Is it that this is what shame looks like?
We know we say Donald Trump doesn't really
seem to be able to feel shame.
Maybe he is able to feel shame and this is
what he looks like and sounds like when he's
feeling shame that this has gone public.
I don't know the answer, but as far as you
know, I, I do think that these conspiracy
theories about Joe Biden are becoming prominent
enough that we probably want to just do a
little bit of a debunking of them.
And of course, I know that there are people
who will say, David, how are you now a Biden
supporter?
Uh, when we talk about this?
But, uh, tomorrow I think it's important.
We don't even know who's going to be the Democratic
nominee.
And I want it to be someone actually progressive
compared to Joe Biden who's a center left
Democrat.
But we can't let these conspiracy theories
about Joe Biden gained momentum and gained
steam.
So probably on tomorrow's show, if not Wednesdays,
I will outline exactly what the allegations
are here against Joe Biden and
we will thoroughly be bumped the David Pakman
show